you don't have to feel what another  person is feeling to want to alleviate  their suffering there's a whole concept  in psychology called intrusive helping  there are a lot of people who um in a  narcissistic way are not paying real  attention to whether or not what they're  giving the other person is actually what  the person needs sometimes we do things  to make ourselves feel good but we need  to actually ask is that really what is  really in best for someone else to look  at the real felt needs of others to  really try to alleviate their suffering  because sometimes we get in all sorts of  trouble by  thinking that we know exactly what  someone else is feeling and we're not  really doing them the best good